you launched your campaign
how confident are you that you will be
the nominee
well nevadans are certainly ready for a
change they they look out and see what's
happening to our country um they see the
the radical lurch to the left and and i
think they're scared they're concerned
they feel under assault you see the rise
of canceled culture
all of that combined with now what you
see in the last week where you've seen
the catastrophic failure in afghanistan
you know i i think we're looking at the
potential of a massive wave election
where people definitely want to send a
message to those that are in power
president biden and masto and the
democrats
at this infrastructure event that was
here in um henderson about an hour ago
at the afl-cio
um unions representing about 45 000
members
standing up um obviously not all 45 000
people were there but there was
leadership from those unions holding up
signs that said
adam laxalt
is a threat to nevada jobs because you
came out and said that you were against
the bipartisan infrastructure bill
are you a threat to nevada jobs
well i mean of course that's a
preposterously political question uh the
question is whether i would have
supported the infrastructure bill you
know
right now nevadans want actual
responsibility out of washington we've
seen trillions of dollars of spending
and what it's led to is
true increase in inflation the democrats
are still somehow saying there's not
inflation but real nevadans know that
gas has gone from three dollars to 450
everything that we spend money on is
going up and so if we continue to just
spend and spend and spend that that
money is not ours we're borrowing that
on on my kids future generations and and
for the moment of time we're in right
now people need to know that that that
gives china more power since they're
buying our debt so this is a grave
concern
and
i would support a real infrastructure
bill in fact there was a bill that could
have had a hundred votes and been a
hundred percent bipartisan bill a bill
that only included bridges and roads
what regular people actually believe is
infrastructure and unfortunately the
senate democrats
passed on that opportunity decided that
they couldn't resist loading this up
with other spending and you know right
now it's just not something we can
afford
if you were elected to the senate uh you
know who knows what the composition's
going to be but minority leader mitch
mcconnell voted for infrastructure
so sort of going against it is going
against
a lot of the
the party
republicans supported this i think you
know 17 19 were probably in support of
this so
what about it don't you like besides the
the cost
look i i'm running to be an independent
voice for that i'm running to be someone
who's actually just going to stand up
consistently for them and uh right now
you know masto just stands with their
party 99 of the time she votes with
chuck schumer and so okay if if mitch
mcconnell supported this one uh i still
don't support it and i'll make those
judgment calls each time for what i
think is right and like i said let's be
very clear i would have been pushing
to get a more narrow bill a bill that
only included bridges and roads and
truck and tunnels what people really
believe our infrastructure this bill was
a christmas list of lots of other
liberal wish lists from washington and
unfortunately we can't afford it
and and i hope that we use the
opportunity for some true bipartisanship
of actually doing a more
more narrowly tailored bill in the
future so what the union leaders were
saying today was that
even though there is yes the the cost to
the to the bill
that all that money gets fueled back to
for you know moms and dads single
parents who might need a job tradesmen
who are looking for work it goes right
back into the economy so they're sort of
saying it pays for itself at the end of
the day by giving people jobs i i don't
think that the extra hundreds of
trillions of dollars that are being
spent is something that nevadans want
right now i understand that people that
are used to unlimited spending which by
the way increases our taxes um you know
i think people are used to say oh 100
million here 500 million there no big
deal but but this is a big deal we are
spending too much we've spent too much
over the last uh last year and if we
keep doing this
anything that may be positive out of
washington is going to be completely
erased by massive inflation increases
and an economy that's going to start
going down rather than up
so if you had been in the senate in 2017
when president former president trump's
tax plan went through would you have
supported that even though it added
trillions to our nation's debt
i i can't say that i know that the
specifics of the bill you're talking
about so
the tax cuts for
wealthiest i certainly would have
supported the tax cuts
they certainly helped the economy and
helped a lot of small businesses helped
a lot of
ordinary families
but but any other details inside the
bill i i can't claim to have a detailed
knowledge of
so obviously you're running against
senator cortez masto what is it
that she hasn't done
that you feel hey i'd do a better job
i flipped the question on you what has
she done
um i i i challenge you you know get on
the street i'm looking talking to your
to your listeners right now
what has she done for nevada and not
just five years as a senator eight years
as an attorney general 13 years what are
the things that come to your mind that
she's done for nevada and i promise you
i speak to people every day people can't
think of anything
because she she hasn't done anything for
nevada certainly as an attorney general
there's no signature thing that she did
and and we had to go in and clean up her
mess that she left in the attorney
general's office
and it's something that i anticipate
we're gonna have to do if i win this
senate race we're gonna have to go in
there and start delivering results for
our state
um
a couple of topics that are going on now
um
should we accept afghan refugees for
what's going on there i think uh first
of all as someone that served in iraq
and did detainee operations in iraq
one of the things that's being lost in
this story is how much effort went into
capturing detainees and how dangerous
these people are there are thousands of
detainees at the bagram prison that were
released and that are out and we have an
open border that senator masto is
refusing to fight to secure and our
country is most certainly less safe
today than it was one week ago without
release and so that is a big priority
and something that we need answers to uh
what are we going to do about these
thousands of really bad folks that have
been released into the international
terrorist network
now as far as prioritization without a
question we have to get americans out
first we have limited resources we just
heard the the secretary of defense say
that we can't guarantee we have no
capacity to go out and bring americans
back to safety so
that has to be first second third
priority how are we going to get all
americans safely in once we get all
americans safely and fine we should try
to take care of those partners that that
were good stewards and that that are
vetted and that we know are safe uh you
know we've always been welcoming to
political refugees and there are going
to be plenty of political refugees
coming out of this terrible afghanistan
situation
so obviously you know
the the war you know it's a 20-year long
war we've had several administrations at
the helm of this thing
is
is it fair to just put all the blame on
the body administration when you've had
three prior administrations
and we're now in this situation it is
fair to put all the blame on the
withdrawal
you're absolutely right it was a 20-year
war i believe that we should have
withdrawn from afghanistan i think that
was most people believed it was time to
get out
we did not need to get out this way
and and that is lies solely at his feet
he's the commander-in-chief is someone's
coming out of the military i mean the
buck actually does stop
with the head of your unit or the
commander
of of your your particular squadron and
uh he said in his speech the buck stops
here but every other word he said the
buck stops somewhere else um and so it's
unfortunate uh that the pictures are
harrowing um the the dangers that the
afghani women are going to face are real
and i just can't even imagine what
they're going
going through
but you know masto she issued a
statement that said i'm observing the
situation
and i hope that the afghani
female leaders that worked with us
aren't harmed i mean that's her
statement so far we need a lot more out
of her challenging what's going on
trying to get the bottom of how these
decisions came to be about
and what are we going to do to rescue
this situation the president i mean it's
almost like sad if it doesn't make you
so angry said
i guess on this 60 minutes interview
that this was just gonna happen there
was no way to stop it
well that's just not true and nobody can
believe that there wasn't a better way
to get out of afghanistan
should people be vaccinated against
covet
i've been vaccinated there's no question
that vaccines reduce your chance of
mortality and they reduce the severity
of infection i also believe that people
absolutely should be able to make their
own decision and people have all sorts
of reasons why they may not decide to
vaccine and i i don't do not like the
coercive side of what's going on with
vaccines right now they're available
people we can keep getting the word out
that they they do reduce the risk of
serious
serious illness and mortality those are
true uh and and and that's unassailable
uh but the government keeps sending
mixed signals of uh incentivizing a
vaccine you don't have to wear a mask
and and then you vaccinate it then you
still have to wear a mask uh they're
trying to force masks on children
which i'm opposed to i think the parents
should be able to choose that
you know people are very very frustrated
with the perpetual onslaught against
their own choice when it comes to kova
we're a year and a half into this now
it's time to treat people like adults
one could argue though that you know i
remember when i was in grade school
and
going to summer camp i had to be
vaccinated i mean against a bunch of
different things when i went to college
i had to get a vaccine
i'm sure you were in the same boat so
wouldn't covet just fall in line with
that
well nobody's debating with the children
getting vaccinated right now it's not
approved for children it's not being
mandated for children and so that's
still going through the process um
but the reality is you know this is an
airborne virus this is this is a
respiratory virus it's not the same
thing as you know measles or smallpox
these are things that vaccines can
actually
basically eradicate uh the vaccine for
covet is
not going to eradicate coded i think our
leaders frankly have been either
intentionally or unintentionally
misleading about that
we are not going to eliminate kobet it
is going to be seasonally coming
through
our country for many many years to come
and so uh thank you for the analogy i
don't think it's correct and i think
that's why this should be treated
differently
uh back in november
you held the press conference that there
was tons of election fraud
those claims were thrown out of state
court federal court
members of your own party said there was
no fraud
um
the secretary of state released a report
and found
24 cases of potential fraud that were
forwarded to your former office the ag's
office was this election fraudulent
i have said from the beginning and i
maintained today that mail-in balloting
was not ready for prime time it was not
going to be a safe
means of election for our state we had
never done it before and it takes states
years and years and years to get that
right
putting mail-in balloting which the
democrats did with no republican votes
three months out before election was not
wise and it was not something that was
ever going to give voters confidence and
so i focused on mail-in signature
verification from beginning to end and i
still maintain that mail-in balloting
was not secure in fact i don't know that
anybody argues that there was not fraud
in mail-in balloting the question is to
what degree and the answer is we still
don't know
and none of the things you mentioned
actually
went through 700 000
mail-in signatures and compared whether
or not they are legitimate and so we
know that certain categories of voters
got in and i've never put a number down
i don't know what the number is it could
be a thousand
well i think you said fifteen pounds or
it could be fifty thousand um we simply
don't we simply don't know the answer
and until you know the media hopefully
before the next elections actually wants
to pour through signatures um and and
once and for all give confidence to our
voters there are democrats there are
independents i'm telling you there are a
wide swath of nevadans that have
concerns about the election and again
i'm always careful to say we don't know
how much fraud there is i could be i i'd
be shocked
but it could be 200 fraudulent voters
that's all there was out of 1.4 million
and of course if we
if we look through these signatures and
that proved to be true i'd be first to
say great i'm really happy we have a
safe election i served in the military
i'm the top law enforcement officer of
the state uh i love this country the
elect election system is imperative that
we believe in it and it's trustworthy
and and uh i hope we get it right so so
should people if if mail-in is a concern
i mean it's the law of the land here in
nevada and the legislature
expanded it for for future elections
should people not vote for you by mail
if if you're concerned about male 1
we've got plenty of time to sort that
out i mean it is it is the the system
now and so we're going to have to
operate in this system um but but i i
certainly hope that we can get have
confidence in mail-in signature voting
uh final final questions um i want to
talk about the the ad you put out um you
know one of the one of the comments is
you didn't mention nevada in it
is there a reason why you didn't name
the state everything i was talking about
are issues that are on nevadans minds
this is what people want someone like me
to fight for um we have nevadans
throughout our entire video thousands of
nevadians nevada's in our video so i'm
not really sure what the critique is and
in the video um
you know it it it points to
some some groups of people that you
might have an issue with including media
so if if the media is a is an issue for
you and and it's in it's in the video
and it's a talking point of yours
why talk to the media and why why talk
to me today
i'm happy to talk to me that i think is
going to be fair and impartial
take that as a compliment i've been very
impartial today and i'll do that every
day uh unfortunately we have a large
percentage of our media that are wearing
the blue jersey and uh sometimes
intentionally and sometimes their
worldview is just so liberal because
they come from these coastal elite
environments they don't even know their
bias but the reality is we have seen the
disappearance of the truly objective
impartial reporter and um it's
the proof is in the pudding
twenty percent of america believe what
media says they've done that to
themselves again i'm not attacking you
this has been a fair interview
but as long as media continues to
distort the truth and to push an agenda
people are going to tune it out which is
a real disservice to our country the
media needs to be a watchdog the media
needs to look at government and
challenge government there was a primary
role in function but what we see now is
media looks very seriously republicans
and then they just totally give a pass
to democrats that's a again i'm not
saying that's you but that is a pattern
we see consistently last question are
you seeking president trump's
endorsement we look forward to having
his support how's he he hasn't endorsed
you yet though correct
we look forward to having his support as
the chair of his campaign um and we look
we look forward to a very strong
campaign i appreciate the time thank you
yeah appreciate